A greater return to self discipline,
I a greater return to foresight and a
much greater willingness to serve
others,
to look for opportunities out of a
American athletes and the affluence they
have joined.
I've enjoyed to try to serve the poor
and needy elsewhere and and also a
recognition that you serve the poor and
needy best if you use the old cliche,
teach them how to fish rather than just
giving them a fish.
The great inner energy of capitalism is
to make things work and to invent and
create new things that didn't exist
before.
New businesses that didn't exist before
and that requires a certain vision and a
willingness to take a chance.
And I see lots of that goodness.
Our new technologies encouraged that
don't they?
I mean all the things possibility and
with communications these days,
they're just amazing.
I see my grandchildren,
they're just fascinated by all the new
technologies,
all the different media and they seem to
lip surrounded by them.
I can hardly understand how to make some
of them work and they do it just like
that.